artists urine huh niche knows how to put
things in a different light he works
with large-scale installations color and
seeing it all in the right viewpoint
Louis bhai immune ha niche I'm a light
artist and metal sculptor from cutbush
[ __ ] bus is a small but really happening
city where you have everything you need
to live I like so much because this town
gives me chances and opportunities I
wouldn't get elsewhere one is this
enormous space for his own light art
gallery well get now I'll show you my
Cutlass tonnages gallery is located
right in the middle of corpuses historic
city centre known also as the Art Walk
it's just a short walk away
yet yarn huh Nagy takes us to the
outskirts of town for his first
recommendation frost pro kleh Park is a
garden based on English landscape design
from the 18th century
the Baroque Granite's palace is also
located here it was built by an
eccentric prince hamad
Ludwik heinrich von kuchler moscow he
lived in these splendid salons in the
19th century
Pickler was also a brilliant landscape
architect himself he worked in a library
which was also his personal refuge is
Alaska I'm particularly fond of being in
this place because this is where Prince
Brooklyn came up with his ideas
developed his designs and saw the park
through to completion for me he's an
inspiration as well so I can recommend
this book Clare was a traveler
fascinated by Egypt he traveled to the
Middle East again and again and brought
back ideas and mementos every time
now it's time for some sustenance so
your own Arnage takes us back to a
charming little soup restaurant in the
old town his second recommendation is
the ideal place for a quick bite to eat
I come here because they've got
different types of meals that are
typical for the region they're delicious
and home made with love no processed
foods are used and you meet and chat
with nice people there's a bit of a
down-home neighborhood feeling to it
that's why I like being here after lunch
urine takes us to what might be the most
imposing site in court for the state
theatre it's a huge art nouveau building
that's recently been fastidiously
restored including these cherubs
the interior is just as elegant as it
was a century ago as an emulsified
measure with the istick the architecture
is what I like about this place even
when you just walk by it grabs you it's
the world of Art Nouveau it's the
exterior details like the cherubs and
the facade and inside there are these
enormous vases it's a completely
different world let's have a look just
come with some on shop and we also get
to catch a bit of a rehearsal for
Arsenic and Old Lace the townspeople are
to thank for this theatre at the end of
the Second World War
orders came to blow up the building than
a munitions depot but the town residents
prevented its destruction so visitors
have the opportunity to see the starry
lights shining down from the cupola it's
a sight to impress anyone including a
light artist like your own homage